let's talk about the best foods that can help
clean out your arteries we're talking about a
problem that involves the inside of the layer
of your arteries it's called the endothelial
layer and if there's a dysfunction with this
layer you get inflammation and you also get
scar tissue fibrosis you also have calcium
buildup and cholesterol buildup and you can
also have a clot which is a little bit different
and one of the absolute best tests to figure out
what's going on on the inside of your arteries
is this right over here it's the coronary
artery calcification test or scan get it from your
doctor it's pretty quick it's not that expensive
it's way more valuable than a cholesterol
test because it's measuring the amount of
calcium buildup in your arteries which is
one of the best predictors or mortality
from all deaths so it's a really important test
it should be zero but sometimes it could be
100 200 500 700 even a thousand or more the key
is if you find that it's very high you want to
apply what i'm going to show you and then retest
it every several months and make sure it's going
down all right starting from number one you
want to make sure that your insulin is normal
okay you don't want it too high and you do that
by dropping your carbs so anything low carb
would be very very therapeutic to your arteries so
you want to do a low-carb diet ketogenic diet and
you want to do fasting okay very very important
because that will lower insulin insulin will cause
inflammation in the inside of the arteries and
the artery will become thickened and you may
even develop a clot there'll be inflammation
and something called age advanced glycated
end products that's a situation that occurs where
the inside of your artery the proteins become
unusable they're damaged and you get this
from consuming too many carbs and you can
also get it from consuming like too many
omega-6 oils which i'll mention a little bit
so this would be number one this is probably the
absolute most important thing you must handle this
or these won't really work number two you
want to consume foods high in vitamin k2
like nato which is a fermented soybean or
liver could be beef liver chicken liver eggs
definitely the yolk grass-fed butter grass-fed
beef sauerkraut maybe a little bit of hard or soft
cheese that has vitamin k2 the vitamin k2 is all
about keeping the calcium out of the arteries all
right number three this is not a food but it's a
very powerful antioxidant tocatrinos is different
than tocopherols this is the vitamin e complex
tocotrinols are 50 times stronger than tocopherols
now if you're consuming green leafy
vegetables you're going to get a good
amount of vitamin e so you can also do that but
if you actually have damage inside your arteries
tocotrinols would be something i would highly
recommend because they're very very powerful they
can stop the fibrosis or scar tissue from getting
any worse and it gets rid of free radical damage
all right number four decreasing omega-6 fatty
acids so you need to get rid of the soy oils the
corn oil the canola the cotton seed out of your
diet and replace that with omega-3 fatty acids
fatty fish salmon cod liver oil you can do walnuts
which has a precursor to omega-3 and also make
sure that if you're doing meats they're grass-fed
it has higher amounts of omega-3 fatty acids
number five to decrease the stiffness of the
arteries which can then lead to high blood
pressure you want to have enough potassium
in the diet potassium keeps the arteries
nice and soft the problem is most people don't
consume enough salad or vegetable to be able to
have enough potassium and they're usually low
an average american has about one and a half
cups of vegetable per day when in fact they need
at least seven or more and so that will give you
the potassium to really help your blood pressure
you can also get it in a good electrolyte powder
now the other thing is vitamin d vitamin d is
very very important in keeping your blood pressure
low it supports this dysfunction in a very big way
it can help your arteries from a lot of different
angles so vitamin d it's almost impossible to get
it from food you can get it from fatty fish and
cod liver oil but the best way is through the sun
or supplement here's the thing you need about at
least 10 000 ius of vitamin d or even more to drop
blood pressure but you'll actually see that blood
pressure will come down when you take it so the
combination of potassium vitamin d is very very
powerful in keeping the arteries from being too
stiff now there's another um good remedy for high
blood pressure pomegranate okay you can get it as
a supplement or consume the seeds in your salad
it has great properties to lower blood pressure
so there you have it some foods to focus on to
keep your arteries clean hey before you
go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today